just ask my next guest desiree andrade a
leader in the recall gas gone movement
her son was brutally murdered back in
2018.
he was repeatedly stabbed beaten
and then he was thrown off a cliff his
body was found two days later
and now thanks to gascon's quote reforms
none of his killers will actually face
life without parole
desiree joins me now desiree
i know people say i'm sorry for your
loss i don't know if it helps but
it's a desperately sad
and infuriating story and as a mother i
i my heart does break for you i'm so
sorry
but your story
could perhaps make a difference here
tell us what you're feeling given what
you're seeing happen day in and day out
at the hands of george gascon
i'm feeling i'm feeling first of all
thank you laura for having me
i'm feeling let down by the justice
system
my son was brutally beaten and tortured
to death
back in may 2018 and the five killers
involved in his murder
are no longer as you mentioned
are no longer facing life without parole
or the death penalty
uh these gentlemen are now facing 25
years and only having to do 80 of that
time which is 20 years that is not
enough my son has a sentence his
sentence was death i will never see my
son again how are they
even how is it even a thought that they
will be out in time to create families
of their own and and do everything that
my son was cheated from so i feel let
down by george gascon i feel it's
personal now i feel that him neglecting
us victims is personal
and for him not to reach out to me as
personal
i think he's a danger to l.a county
point blank
what was the reaction
of your son's murderers when they found
out
that they'd be
they'd be getting out in 20 years
uh
it was sickening actually my daughter
and i sat in court
as
one of them
gave a fist fist bump to his attorney
and
his attorney looked at him like good job
and was smiling from ear to ear and
it was done all in front of me which was
a slap in the face
it just goes to show you where we're at
criminals are now considered victims
what are we doing here
it's the other way around i feel that
they are getting more justice than we
the victims are and and it's not right
at all i want to show some good news
here uh desiree uh which is the current
polling about this george soros
supported d.a mr gascon
25 approval rating a 40.8 percent
disapproval rating
and 61 percent sell the say they'll vote
for an unnamed alternative candidate
your message to democrat women in this
state who just can't feel like they
they can vote to vote against a democrat
that's in office like george gascon
because you need
about you know
you need 580 000 signatures uh by
october 27th to get this recall
uh in order so what's your message to
them tonight
i'm a democrat we need to all wake up
this is not a political stance this is
not a prolific political effort this is
about a fight for what's right and
what's wrong we need to wake up
we need to commit com
get together as a community as
angelinos and get this man out of office
i'm telling you all you do not want to
be in my place you do not ever want to
lose your son
you do not ever want to be a part of
this
right here you do not want to be a part
of this violence you do not want to be
about this destroyed commute criminal
justice system it's just gone wrong so
please everybody wake up these polls
mean nothing without these signatures we
need signatures please go to recall
george gascon download the petition sign
we need this him out this is now down to
crunch time and i i just do not want him
to stay in office he is a danger like i
said i am scared i am scared for our
safety please i am begging all of you to
please take this very seriously
desiree um i don't i don't recognize la
i first came here in 1984 i thought i
had died and gone to heaven it was the
most credible place
watching your pain the pain of so many
parents
everything that's happening here it's
unacceptable it's completely
unacceptable i will post
the link to the website so we can get
more signatures
we will be in touch with you obviously
before the october deadline
but this cannot be for naught desiree
thank you for sharing this story i know
it is incredibly difficult for you and
we really appreciate it
thank you for having me again i'm
incredibly blessed thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else